but first to the breaking news out of
Israel the IDF striking Gaza in the
biggest offensive yet 21 days this has
been going on let's go straight to Trey
yingst who's on the ground in southern
Israel and Trey told us a short time ago
uh this is the most that you have seen
the biggest escalation in this war to
date absolutely over the past several
hours we've been watching as the Israeli
Air Force hammers the Gaza Strip with
air strikes in the distance you'll hear
some explosions when the sky lights up
that is an indication they are striking
Targets in the northern part of Gaza
above me you might be able to hear the
buzz of an Israeli drone trying to pick
out the next targets for the Israelis
it's not just the air campaign though
also on the ground the Israelis are
pushing forward their artillery units to
hammer the Eastern side of Gaza as
ground forces do enter in a limited but
expanded according to the Israeli
military raid now we should make the
distinction here this is not according
to the military the fullscale ground
operation that is anticipated but it is
a much larger raid than we have seen the
past several nights along the border
here we've heard tanks firing into the
Gaza Strip we've heard machine gun fire
and sources inside Gaza telling us they
can hear those explosions there even as
far down as the southern part of the
Gaza Strip remember Gaza is 25 miles
long to give you a sense though just
throughout the day what this has looked
like rocket fire still coming off of
Gaza 20 51 days into this conflict
targeting not just Southern but also
Central Israel sending hundreds of
thousands of people to bomb shelters
guys back to
you Trey um can you just give us some
idea um what you have seen and heard so
far and you know if this was indeed the
full-scale ground Invasion that has been
anticipated how we would know that
indeed is
happening it's a great question and we
spoke today in person in Tel Aviv
Israel's second largest city with yav
gallan the country's defense minister
and I asked him a a number of questions
about the expected ground operation
especially about the timing and he told
me that once it begins this is not a
question of weeks but rather months you
can hear that explosion there some
outgoing artillery fire into the Gaza
Strip this is a very active front line I
can hear the fighter jets overhead to
give you a sense of what we've been
hearing and seeing like I said you'll
see a large explosion and then the sky
lights up a loud boom in the distance
but it's not just here that is facing
this front it's all over Israel because
despite the Israeli air strikes that
have continued since the October 7th
Massacre of so many innocent people here
that kicked off this ground war in the
Middle East there has been continued
rocket fire toward major population
centers just today a few hours ago we
were taking fire here Aid Sirens were
sounding you only have about 10 seconds
to respond at this location so we had to
rush to a nearby shelter and in Tel Aviv
they have a little bit more time but
they are facing similar scenarios and we
really should note that while we talk
about the bombs and the bullets and the
air strikes the civilian population here
is paying such a heavy price the
psychological trauma of living amid this
War 3 weeks in following a brutal
Massacre against the civilian population
is is so difficult for the Israeli
people and for the Jewish state to
consume and inside Gaza more than 2
million Palestinians there we are
talking with them tonight a few of them
do have the ability to text despite the
fact that communication is down along
the strip anyone that has a foreign SIM
card is able to get signal off of an
Israeli cell tower and I've been trying
to get more color of what's taking place
inside Gaza but as we speak and you can
hear the Jets overhead a ground war is
unfolding before our eyes and Israel's
defense minister telling Fox News today
this will last for months guys Trey it's
it's Janine Piro here now we've heard
most of the day that this is a limited
raid uh and that the heavy artillery
comes after this but there is a a report
new from axius that says axios it says
Israel's war cabinet decided to expand
ground operations in Gaza after talks on
a possible hostage release with Hamas
reached a stalemate two Israeli
officials told axio um and uh so now it
appears and and I don't I'm curious to
whether or not you have any information
on this that this may be you know the
bigger raid based upon the failure of
Hostage
negotiations so I've been working
throughout the night talking with
Western intelligence sources and also
Regional sources who are familiar with
the hostage situation today the Israelis
actually raised the number of hostages
being held inside Gaza to
229 people and as they get more
information and proof of life for those
Israelis that were dragged into Gaza on
October 7th they will update the number
in terms of the timing of tonight's
expanded raid it's challenging to say
exactly why because this this all has to
do with the situation on the ground and
I want to just read you a few notes that
I took today much of the conversation
was off the record with Israel's defense
minister but we were able to get some
information on the record clear to
report to you now and I want to take you
through the mission of the Israeli army
they give us four points of what they
are trying to do they say the first one
the destruction of hamas's military and
governing capability along the strip the
second one returning those hostages that
are being held we do understand there
are high level negotiations going on
behind the scenes remember already four
have been released to American citizens
and to Israeli citizens the third on the
list here securing Israel's Southern
Arena where we're at right now and then
finally deterring Israel's adversaries
in the region and you have to remember
Iranian proxies exist across the Middle
East not just in the Gaza Strip with
Hamas and Islamic Jihad but also in
Lebanon with the Lebanese militant group
Hezbollah that's fired anti-tank
missiles into Northern Israel hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else